ils seraient huit mille mais ils sont
nombreux à n'avoir pas été diagnostiquée
ils ce sont les malades d'alzheimer du
nom du médecin neuropathologiste
allemand qui a découvert cette maladie
la journée mondiale de lutte contre la
maladie d'alzheimer organisée le 21
septembre dernier a été l'occasion de
rappeler l'importance de parler encore
et encore de cette maladie dégénérative
qui fait sombrer les patients dans
l'oubli une journée qui fut aussi
l'occasion d'échanger lors d'une table
ronde à l'espace réglé sur invitation de
france alzheimer réunion sur le thème
est reproché dans en activité
professionnelle on est souvent un moment
de sa vie où on devient les parents de
ses parents en quelque sorte
et quand on a justement un parent qui
est qu'on a vu qu'on a connue en pleine
forme et qui complètement bon avec la
maladie on sait très difficile à vivre
alors on a sa vie à côté
quelquefois on a une activité
professionnelle c'est justement le thème
de la de la rencontre de ce soir décès
de parler des aidants qui sont en qui
ont encore une activité professionnelle
et qu'il faut à tout prix et d en fait
là les aidant ils sont là pour aider le
malade mais nous on est on doit pouvoir
faire tout ce qui est en notre pouvoir
pour aider ces personnes là qui donnent
de leur temps et qui sont là par amour
pour leurs familles bien évidemment pour
leurs malades mais c'est important de
les aider un sujet important puisqu'ils
sont nombreux ces proches aidants à
devoir trouver des solutions pour
concilier la vie professionnelle
familiale et cet accompagnement de l'an
de leurs proches attentes de la maladie
les échanges ont montré à quel point ces
personnes sondées lui et qu'ils doivent
faire face un parcours administratif
compliqué tout en faisant face à la
maladie avec pour conséquence une grande
détresse psychologique
china base s'occupe de sa mère depuis
maintenant deux ans j'en ai besoin mais
je pense que je pas la seule qui en est
besoin
et voilà c'est vrai qu'à difficulté
quand on quand on côtoie
cette maladie on a l'impression d'entrer
dans un monde à part dans un monde
tellement particulier qu'on a tendance à
ressentir un certain isolement quand ma
main on a beau lutter contre je pense
que c'est un isolement qui vous rattrape
quotidiennement et avec des difficultés
qu'on sous estime qu'on est loin loin
loin d'estimer lorsqu'on n'est pas dans
ce monde et voilà j'ai beaucoup d'espoir
dans cette conférence ce soit pour
reprendre une respiration pour pouvoir
voir un peu mieux aussi où on va et
mieux comprendre tout simplement ce qui
se joue et être présent au quotidien de
mieux en mieux auprès de notre main
d'henry pour accompagner ces aidants le
conseil départemental a mis en place
plusieurs dispositifs par le biais du
gps ap le conseil départemental qui
soutient également la prise en charge
des malades atteintes de la maladie
d'alzheimer
le cheval de bataille du conseil
départemental c'est d'aider de venir en
aide à ces grands mots latins et bien
évidemment à leur famille qu'ils se
battent jour le jour pour justement
trouver des solutions pour relancer
malades en y apportant une aide
financière bien évidemment et aussi en
matière de conseil en matière du journée
départementale comme ça va se faire
bientôt le 6 octobre prochain dans le
cadre des aidants familiaux à ce
moment-là tout
un panel de
deux professionnels y sera pour apporter
un soutien moral
un soutien
communiquer communiquer sur la maladie
et dire aux gens que ils ne sont pas
seuls au fait c'est enfin millions le
conseil départemental est là pour les
aider
55 % des aidants au entre 30 et 59 ans
47 % des aidants soit environ 4 millions
de personnes occupent un emploi des
aidants qui sont majoritairement des
femmes particulièrement vulnérables
c'est d'ailleurs dans ce but que
plusieurs dispositions de la loi pour
l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement a pour objet la
reconnaissance la valorisation et
l'encouragement pour ses proches aidants
familiaux qui pour certains exercent une
activité professionnelle